welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 13 and
we're gonna learn the abilities that
billionaires have
enjoy
[Music]
somebody once said that the chains of
habit
are too light to be felt until they're
too heavy to be broken
i had been terrified of public speaking
i couldn't do it i'd throw up and i knew
if i didn't cure it then
i never cured and so i
saw an ad in the paper for the dale
carnegie course
which worked on developing your ability
to speak in public
and i went down there
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail on a puppy
they made us all these crazy things to
get out of ourselves and so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if i hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
so in my office you will not see the
degree i got from the university of
nebraska
you'll not see the master's degree i got
from columbia university
but you'll see the little award
certificate i got from the dale carnegie
of course first of all you don't need
college learning learn stuff
okay everything is available basically
for free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
there is a value that colleges have
which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's is
can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of sort of annoying
homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh and and kind of soldier through and
and get it done
you know that's that's like the main
value of college and then also you know
if you you
probably want to hang around with a
bunch of people your own age for a while
instead of going right into the
workforce um
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning
you need people who and this is very
tricky
you need people who are experts
in a certain domain area because the
world is so complex today it's really
hard to invent something if you're
if you're not an expert if you don't
have the underlying tools
at your disposal and know what's going
on you can't you know invent something
in
neurosurgery without knowing something
about neurosurgery
um it's just going to be very difficult
because we're very advanced and that's
true in every
every field of endeavor but to really be
an inventor
you have to combine that expertise with
the beginner's mind
you have to have a certain child-like
ability
to not be trapped by your expertise
and that fresh look that beginner's mind
once you're an expert
is unbelievably hard to maintain but
great inventors
are always looking they have a certain
divine discontent and
they may have seen something a thousand
times and still
it occurs to them that that thing even
though they're accustomed to it
could be improved and that's you know
you have to look for people like that
and i also think cultures support that
you know you can't even if you're that
kind of person
if you're in a culture that doesn't
support failure
you know willingness to fail is critical
for invention willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
you know
most inventions don't really work that
well in the beginning
they're clumsy they're little toddlers
they're always falling and tripping
and so you have to have a a a culture in
your organization that supports this
kind of
stumbling and wandering you know you
want just because you're wandering
doesn't mean you're lost
and that's a really important thing to
keep in mind when you're
trying to invent we are in this really
huge
secular transition away from degrees
towards skills
it no longer matters where you went to
school what you did
don't tell me you have an mba it's
irrelevant it's useless
who gives a sh learn to code
and you'll be employed for the rest of
your life i lost a kid
24 year old kid to a big company in
cupertino
where he got paid 175 grand a year
and 600 000 guaranteed over four years
in rsu's
and this he's not done anything ever
okay so all of you should teach your
kids how to code
all of you you should learn how to code
but my point is it's about skills now
and so that's another reallocation of
trillions of dollars
in life you want to be your own
quarterback see the playing field
many people like to get myopically tied
into one thing
and they have a hard time stepping back
being ceo of microsoft is this amazing
wonderful opportunity
turns out everybody in the world wants
to tell you what to do
and they'll educate you you want to
learn about any field of technology
as long as you don't act like a
know-it-all somebody will educate you
and you have a unique ability to see
broadly across the technology field
to right now i'm spending a lot of my
time studying
government and the economy turns out the
number of places you can
actually read about the totality of
government in the united states is
almost zero
what is the total spend in government in
this country
and what does it get spent on there's no
government report on that topic
the best site happens to come from some
random blogger who i met
who i think is great by the way but i
found him through our bing search engine
not surprisingly uh
but that's my only plug for today
i'm still a shareholder but seeing the
field
i think the the quality that uh
has helped me in lots of things is
a kind of measurement scientific
framework where i go in and say did
anybody handle this well
what are the very best practices do we
have numbers on that
and let's get everybody measuring what
they're doing
and so they can strive to match
what that the best achievement is for us
often that's
something like getting the vaccines out
to all the children
some very poor countries do that
extremely well because they get down to
that local level and measure the
activity they make sure the inventory is
there they make sure the workers are
showing up
so for me i always look at how can we do
better
better measurement and use that to drive
the very best practices many of you
as i have been as i am are where you are
in your life based upon what you believe
and it's not just what you
think you believe on the surface it's
also your
shadow beliefs that are holding you back
from moving
into the life that you believe you
deserve
what i know is if you're not looking at
the shadows if you're not looking at
what is
subconsciously running through the tape
in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough you're not enough which is
a tape that's playing for a lot of
people
if you're not conscious of that then you
end up acting out of
that belief system and not out of what
you know to be the truest or want to be
the truest for yourself
but you don't become what you want
because so much of wanting is about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why jim carrey's story
is so powerful because he started to act
as though he already had it
he would go up to mulholland drive he
would drive away saying
thinking i already have those things i
just haven't accessed them
as yet i believe those things are going
to come to me and i'm going to
act like they are so i'm going to move
forward in my life in order to
draw that to myself in such a way that
my actions are in alignment with
what i say i believe so if you start to
think about that
really why are you where you are in your
life
the choices that you have made have been
because of what you believe to be true
for yourself
what is it about selling the that you
actually enjoyed that
you think most people most people don't
enjoy selling so what is it about
selling that you actually
well okay this is the first thing i'm
going to say if you don't like
selling you should really take the time
for yourself
to practice it and learn it because all
of life is sales
i mean whether you're an accountant
whether you're a stay-at-home mother and
you're trying to sell your kids on why
they need to go to bed at a certain time
or they need to do something that you
need them to do
in an interview you have to sell
yourself i mean and so
um i think it's really important to be
able to to do that and
and hardcore door-to-door sales was
incredible groundwork
and laid that laid the foundation for me
to be able to do spanx
because when i started spanx the first
two years that i was cold calling all
the
manufacturers in north carolina i only
heard one word
no yeah i mean no no no
and because i had training and just knew
i'm gonna keep going till i get that yes
that's the reason that i was able to get
through that stage
i focus on things that are ai driven
artificial intelligence driven whether
it's machine learning deep learning
learning neural networks
um medical applications but within
ai ai is a buzzword that everybody's
using right now you know every
and and to that point you know
we as old guys we go back and it's like
1995 we talk about the internet
and i would say to people back in 1995
look if you don't understand the
internet you're not going to be able to
do business
and now that's just blocking the
tackling it seems obvious back then it
wasn't
right i could even take you further back
to my first company you know what we did
it was a company called micro solutions
and we did local area networks on wide
area networks
and i used to walk into companies and
and say you're going to have to hook
these pcs together at some point
that'll make you more productive more
effective you know give you a
competitive advantage and
people are like now i just carry this
floppy from this pc
to that pc yeah okay um
but today we're at the same type of
inflection point
with artificial intelligence you don't
have to be an expert and
be able to put together your own neural
network you know you don't have to know
what weights and biases are
but but you have to have more than just
a cursory understanding
just like you have to know the
difference between you know
different types of websites and you have
to understand e-commerce if you're in
e-commerce
you have to have a cursory understanding
of how
apps work you're going to have to have
at least if not more
cursory understanding of artificial
intelligence because it will change
everything we do and if the internet was
10x in terms of change to business
artificial intelligence will be 100x or
more
so there's going to be a disruption and
change
in the types of jobs that's going to
impact your customers that's going to
impact your businesses
that's going to impact the future of
business and so
i can't i don't want to be you know
i want to be as clear and as forceful as
i possibly can
because as fellow entrepreneurs we
always have to look for an edge
we always have to understand how our
industry is changing we always have to
understand
not only how we differentiate ourselves
and our companies
but you always i always want to know who
can kick my ass right
and all my businesses who can kick my
ass and can i kick my own ass first
because if you can disrupt yourself
first you're
the person who could otherwise do it is
not going to do it
and you can compete and be successful so
pay attention to ai
it's important i mean look if you go to
my house
right next to my bed there's a book
machine learning for dummies
if you go into my bathroom there's deep
neural networks for dummies
right if you go on there's something for
dummies
in every room of my house you know
[Music]
it can go two ways i know but i'm just
telling you
put the time i mean i i've taken you
know i can't even tell you how many
hours now i spend every week
if not daily working like i'll go into
amazon aws
and go through their machine learning
tutorials don't think to yourself i'm
not technical enough or i'm not going to
get this or i don't get into this or
it's too much try it get as far as you
can because
it's like doing a basic website and a
little bit of html
just having done that you feel smarter
and you feel a little bit more confident
about this
you know i don't want to be an alarmist
but i'm trying to scale the hell out of
you because it's important
in the world of entrepreneurship the big
skills are kind of
programming skills and people skills
like those are the big two
and i think people skills tend to be
highly underestimated
um in terms of uh kind of just ability
to run a company and so forth and what i
mean by people skills
the ability to understand um other
people's motivation
and other people's motivations who
you're talking to and then who you're
also not talking to
and how they're going to think about
something and where they're coming from
and relate to that in a way that gets
you to the right conclusion about how
you build an organization or build a
company or
or you know make a deal or any of these
kinds of things is
incredibly valuable and that's what i
would say
most of the kind of
good entrepreneurs end up lacking more
than the technical skills that we
see now like being like a boss level
engineer like that's extremely valuable
i'm not discounting that
but uh that that's really the other big
big skill that you can learn
in in school what are your core values
personally and professionally
uh core values are i would say it's the
golden rule
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you
that's the basis for most religions but
they get sometimes carried away in
rights and rituals
but that's the core value do unto others
as you'd have others do unto you
and then it's the feeling of knowing
that success
unshared is definitely failure in other
words when you make it
it's not really just about yourself
making it hey if you make it you know
you made it
but along the way one of the great
lessons to learn
is it's not all about you it's about
your ability to be of service to this
planet while you're here
and by saying me me me me look what i
did this is me
hey here's my building my name's on it
you know i did this you didn't
by doing something like that it kind of
takes away
from how genuine you are and because
people don't like to just listen to
people talk about themselves how great
they are
they want to know incorporate it to make
them successful also or do something a
little different and i think that's very
very important
you got to get some skills you want to
get rich
the dude that owns that house
knows how to sell things okay cat that
owns that house by the way
dude's only here about six weeks at a
year he's here four weeks in a year
both these dudes learned how to sell
products how to market
how to promote that's what cardone u is
cardon u was the first break i got in my
whole life
i was 25 years old broke and my uncle
said you look you need to learn how to
sell because nobody else is hiring i'm
like i didn't go to college to learn how
to be a salesman
and he's like dude you didn't go to
college
to be out of work i said okay let's go
get that job
because that made so much sense to me i
just spent almost five years in college
and and i am out of work and he says you
did not go to college to be out of a job
out of income and in an unemployment
line so i wouldn't got me a sales job
and then i learned how much i hated
sales in fact i
i hated losing because i didn't know how
to sell
and another man told me that he's like
you don't like sales dude because you
don't know how to do it
i said what do you what do you mean he's
like if you if you were selling
something every day if you were making a
commission every day
if you were successful with people every
day if you know how to communicate to
people
and get people to say yes to you if you
knew how to turn a yes into a no
oh sorry a no into a yes it's the
altitude okay if you knew how to turn
every no into a yes every objection into
a close
every problem stall
and you had a rebuttal a professional
rebuttal
that didn't sound salesy that didn't
make you sound like a
a a you know a car salesman dude if you
were a pro
professional with every customer that
said no to you and you got all them to
say yes to you you would love it
your problem grant is you don't have any
skills son
you're trying to sell off a personality
and the truth is i was a bit of an
introvert scared of people
didn't know how to say anything to him
in the beginning the opening was the
hardest thing for me
that is until i got to the close and
then that was the hardest thing for me
and so for the first two years that i
was in sales damn door's still locked
didn't somebody notice that first two
years i was in sales
i hated every second of it and then i
skilled up
then i got on a program it wasn't card
on university at that time but i got on
a guy's program
my entire life turned around because
this one guy on a program on an old
betamax tape
12 tapes taught me
the importance of selling communication
controlling communication controlling
people
how to turn objections into closes how
to turn
uh one close into two deals how to
upsell
how to follow up professionally how to
become a professional salesperson
that no one would do anything except say
man you're good at your job dude oh whoa
you're good
i didn't plan on buying anything you're
smooth
you know and that was the first level
the second level was nobody even knew
they were buying anything
okay that's how we raised 100 plus
million dollars in charity last year
selling
that's how i started buying real estate
convincing people to
sell the property to me that's how i got
a loan on a real estate deal
okay oh fannie mae and freddie mac about
380 million dollars today let me tell
you something
you got to be a salesman you don't need
good credit you need to be able to
convince fannie and freddie
that they should lend you money on the
deal
okay so one change the way you think
okay because i know
i know good sales people that never
change the way they think and they never
become
financially free sales people they
become good sales people
they make a couple hundred grand a year
i think they're freaking killing
it but they could never take a trip like
this okay now this would be one of two
trips that we take this year
i don't need a 20 bedroom house i don't
need it we didn't have 20 people coming
here
there's one reason i bought i rented
this place because this place had two
bunk beds
captain ryan by the way is the one that
told me he kept his captain ryan
okay let if you know if you don't know
captain ryan you want to know i'm doing
that video you told me to do awesome
okay and i'm telling her the three
things they need to know captain ryan by
the way he flies
a plane happens to be my plane
happens to be my plane so now i'm
passing your plane now i'm bragging
right now i tell you right now i'm
bragging okay
i'm bragging because nobody taught me my
mom
my dad died when i was 10. so he
couldn't teach me this i don't know that
he would have
taught me this if he'd lived but nobody
in my household
in my entire lineage in 200 300 years
ever thought about ever mentioned
hey you should fly private you should go
where you want when you want
get there when you want leave when you
want
on your terms go where you want change
your schedule if you want to
bring your family and your staff stay as
long as you want to stay ski as much as
you want or don't
buy a week worth of tickets and use them
or don't use them
see that's freedom that's why you want
money okay so number one change the way
you think
you got to undo that that's what what i
talked about in the millionaire book
i talked about in playbook the millions
second thing you have to do is you got
to get skills cardone university
is basically that program that i bought
when i was 25 years old
that taught me how to become a master
salesperson but it's that program
on steroids it's how to sell on the
internet
how to market how to promote how to
follow up
uh how to do a one-call close how to do
cold calls
how to do warm calls how to get
referrals how to build a pipeline how to
negotiate
how to close how to work one dollar
deals and 100 million dollar deals
1500 segments of content sit there okay
so if you're an entry-level salesperson
sooner or later you've got to learn how
to do this
okay the wife i have she didn't want to
go out with me
she's an actress she's hot man she's
amazing okay
she did not want to go out with me
because i wasn't an actor so what did i
do
i put my sales skills on her it was a
sales job
when i get my kids to do things it's a
sales job right when i buy an apartment
building
it's a sales job i buy a 30 million
dollar deal i paid 26 million for it
there was another guy in line
willing to pay 30. that's a sales job
how do you negotiate
save yourself money at the beginning of
a deal and then sell the deal for more
money later that's how you make money
that's how you create freedom the third
thing
you got it number one change your mind
number two you gotta learn the sales
game you gotta learn the sales game at
some point number three thing
okay do you gotta surround yourselves
with with some great people
okay that's why i do these retreats i
want great people around me
removed from my crazy environment the
third thing you must do and you've heard
it over and over and over again is
change
your friends and how do you change your
friends okay
you're gonna change your friends because
you gotta get some money
okay you can't hang around broke people
and expect to be rich
you can't hang around people that are
just getting by and expect
to live a rich life you cannot help your
church or your favorite charity
if the people around you are broke you
could be rich
and still be broke because everybody
around you is broke
i measure my success today by how many
people around me are doing well
i don't want my wife worried about money
i don't want captain ryan worried about
money i don't want my ceo worried about
money
i don't want the people that work in my
company worried about money i want them
to be able to come on a trip with me
and be productive while they're gone not
go home to money problems
because a person is having money
problems will never ever be truly
productive
you live on an economic planet
regardless of your race regardless of
where you came from regardless of your
religion
you live on a planet that has two things
on it gravity
i can't fly and i'm reminded every day
of gravity right or wrong
every day day i'm reminded i'm reminded
of it so much i don't even know that
it's not normal that i shouldn't be able
to jump seven feet right
and number two money every day
you were reminded this is a financial
planet okay
i got a little credit i don't have any
cash on me today not because i'm a real
estate guy
real estate guys are always broke okay
but i got me a little card i can use
this to open boxes
and i can use it to buy a box right see
how many you were told all
credit credit cards are bad how many
been told debt is bad how many been
trained that
oh all debt is bad debt i got about 500
million
worth of debt i got to tell you i love
it almost as much as my wife and kids
[Music]
i do love it man because it generates
income for me
now i'm telling you all this to tell you
look you have been miseducated if you're
having trouble with money it's because
you have the wrong data
it's not because you're stupid it's not
because you're lazy it's not because you
have a bad job
okay i've had all those excuses you have
the wrong information the first 25 years
of my life i
use the information that is being
disseminated
by tv and mass media save your money
say yeah if you heard that one okay you
were brought up on that one if you were
brought up poor middle class
say yay no no you can't say it like that
say it like you're proud yes i was poor
say yay no no well you brought up poor
middle class
[Music]
i'm gonna tell you something it's gonna
take you forever if you don't get your
freaking enthusiasm right
look if you're poor admit it
[Music]
but damn i'm poor and then hate it
because you shouldn't be if you're in
the middle by the way if you're middle
class and you got three meals a day
you got a car out there you can make the
payments on you got a little
education that you think is worth
something and it's not
okay and you got a good mom and a good
dad and you're brought up in a good
family good for you but dude i don't pay
the bills
you don't have more money folks because
now it's not it's not because you don't
work
it's not because you're not a good
person it's not because you overspend
it's not because you got too much debt
it's not because you don't bust your ass
it's because your money doesn't bust its
ass
your money is lazy if your money
was employees you would fire your money
okay i mean would you tell would you
tell your money
okay here i earned all this money now
i'm gonna go invest in something i don't
know anything about
imagine if i get a million dollars if i
get a million dollars
and i save a million dollars or i save
ten thousand dollars
just convert your money to employees
these are people
do i want these million people to work
for me do i want these employees
these 10 000 employees to go work for me
you guys don't have it working you've
got to stay in in your house
you're like no no i don't want my 10 000
employees to work for me i'm gonna park
it
in my house you would never do that but
that's what you have you have ten
thousand
or a thousand ben franklin's basically
living at your house
doing nothing dying or
you put them in the 401k this is a scam
of
massive proportions right here send the
money to the 401 k
people are like hey man your fund's 10
years that's freaking 35 and 40 years
this is
ridiculous right here you send money
every month maybe a
500 bucks a month every month to go die
and you can't even access the money so
here's the rules okay number one
the the money the extra money should go
into something that gives you money
you want your money to have babies the
golden goose is no long
no longer good if she doesn't have
eggs the only thing that makes the
golden goose valuable is the fact that
the golden goose
legs lays eggs so if you just study the
wealthiest families
in the world not just in america in the
world over long periods of time
look at the queen the queen of england
this much property and one of the
richest families in the world why
they get cash flow every month
from india from england from ireland
from all over the world
why why are the princes in saudi arabia
so wealthy because they have constant
inflow of money coming from the land
that produces the oil the oil comes out
of the land
and produces cash flow the railroads the
railroads back in the day what'd they do
they got all this land together and then
they rented that land out to everybody
around it
why do all the teachers credit unions
take all the money from all the teachers
around america
and then they start investing in real
estate that produces cash flow
so they can distribute back to their
members
i'm always going to come back to this
one story look real assets
that produce real cash flow every month
when it pays you every month
and you're getting reminded every month
i got a check i got a little hundred
dollar check
i got a 200 check this month i got a 13
000 check today from one of my
properties
every month i get a check for 13 grand
from that property
it's 150 000 a year it didn't start like
that it used to be like 1300 bucks 1300
then it was 26
then it was 5 000. next thing you know
it's 13 grand that's one property
pays me every month property just sits
there
okay it just sits there it might not
even change in value it just sits there
and produces cash flow anything that
produces cash flow
will be worth more money tomorrow that's
why netflix is valuable
why because people pay a lot of cash
into netflix
and even if netflix loses money today
some company will find
netflix desirable for one reason
flow is king okay particularly if the
technology can't be disrupted
so the cash flow at at t is less
desirable than the cash flow at netflix
because you have so much disruption
going on with telecommunications
as opposed to i want to watch tv at
night see john
john here he's on the camera today john
puts his money in the mattress
where do you keep it john behind the
closet
yeah yeah he's got he's got it triple
closeted by itself
okay he his money's homophobic
he's in three closets but it's all alone
dude if you stay alone
you cannot multiply and this is the
biggest mistake people make they don't
get their money to work
what your mom and dad taught you will
not get you to the next level
okay the reason you don't have more
money let's talk to our next caller
the reason you don't have more money is
the money you do have
you don't have a place for it to go to
work
cody what's up hey how are you doing man
cody i'm doing good now that i'm talking
to you
hey so my question is i'm new at
starting out uh i just got into sales
like six months ago
um so i don't have a lot of money like
maybe two thousand dollars how does
someone starting out
so small 10x their money
well how much money do you have right
now like two thousand dollars
good so your next target is 20 grand you
just multiply it times ten
two thousand i gotta go from two
thousand to twenty thousand dollars
right and so right now but you're like
how fast can i do that
so i'm gonna be like i want need i need
to make like 30 000
to keep 20 or i need to make 40 to keep
20 because that's really your goal now
i'm gonna go 10x and then i'm gonna do a
double because for me to keep 20 grand i
need to make more than 20 because the
government and food
and the cost of living is going to take
some of it so now your new target's 40
grand i'm gonna make 40 i'm gonna keep
20 i'm gonna go from having two grand
to twenty thousand dollars number one
number two how fast can i do it
the speed at which you can do this will
determine how much money you have left
over
the longer it takes you to get there the
less money you're going to end up with
the shorter the period of time the more
you can compress time
so dude if you if you were committed
enough you could do that between now
and the end of the year the fact that
you've never accumulated that much money
in your life
does not mean with a target and a a real
desire to do it
i could go get 40 grand this afternoon
yeah i mean i'm 100 committed to this
yeah i started watching your videos
you know i'm looking into the grant
cardone university
um you should get that you should get
cardone university by the way you should
get that because it's going to show you
how to talk to people
because if you can't talk to people you
can't get money because who's got all
the money
people exactly people like i want more
money go talk to people
like what do you think the money is dude
it's not in the air it's not an idea the
money's not sitting up in your head i
got to think about something no you
don't do you got to go talk to people
because people have everything you want
so you got 10 000 that you earned from
hard
work you walked away you made 20 grand
you paid your taxes
you paid some sneakers for the kids you
did this for a while
you ended up with 10 000 little babies
over here 10
000 little baby bennies
and you're like man what am i gonna do
with this money your goal should be to
earn five to six percent on your money
in ten years that money will be fifty
percent you will have earned fifty
percent
number one you wanna earn cash flow
number two you need to be
in something that has the potential
to go up and appreciate and zero
potential to go down
listen to what i'm telling you this is
all you have to do this is what i've
done for 30 years
i make money work my ass off make some
money pay my
bills live frugally i have some leftover
money all decisions now are to get that
money to work
this is why people don't get rich they
never get their money to work
they go buy a house they go on a
vacation they buy a car i'm like dude i
didn't want to do all that i wanted to
get rich
i want this money to earn more money
than i
earn and you just have to do this over
time it takes time to do this the goal
should be
i earn more money because of my money
than i earn
because of my time time is money
study this it's not money it's time it's
time is money nobody ever says
money is time you can't buy time time
is money right so what do i do i earned
the money now i got 10 grand everybody's
got 10 grand everybody can find 10 grand
now i got to decide to get rid of the 10
grand if you hold the 10
you will not multiply the money the
money will go down in value money
sitting around always goes down in value
so number one i need cash flow
cash flow is keen the more
the lower the cash flow by the way the
lower the cash flow the more stable the
cash flow
the better the appreciation is going to
be in the future i did not know this
when i started investing
i wanted higher cash flow you want to
actually a lower
cash flow better better assets
pay lower cash flows better assets
appreciate faster
right so you need two parts of the
equation one get rid of money
get rid of the cash if you don't do the
first thing you will never ever have
more money
okay earn five to six percent of your
money and be
in an asset a real asset not a piece of
paper
that's a piece of paper stocks are not
real assets
okay in a real asset that has the
potential this is the definition
it has the potential to be worth more
and zero potential at being worth less
it cannot go down in value
if you do those two things and do it
over and over and over again i flew into
lake charles louisiana where i grew up
a guy says hey man i got to know i grew
up with this kid
he was the next door neighbor his daddy
was a doctor
this guy is in tight been entitled his
whole life he's like
my god man i mean he grew up with money
he's been going to aspen since he was
six years old
right in a ski boat every summer his ski
boat he's never not had money
like this guy should be light years
ahead of me but he's not
he's like my god you got the world by
the tail dude he's like what's the
secret
dude i found out what works and i do it
over and over and over and over again
while you were going on trips to aspen
and you were buying a house
showing off i wasn't buying a house and
i wasn't going to aspen
what i was doing was buying stuff that
would pay me that works harder for me
than my kids will
i don't even know my kids will work but
i'm gonna get ben franklin to work i got
money in my pocket right now i'm a
little worried about it because it's not
working
it needs to do something go hustle man
okay all right let's talk to our callers
today paul in las vegas why don't you
have more
money i don't know i'm at work right now
i'm talking to you
yeah but dude but dude let's talk about
it might be the issue why don't
how much money you have at the bank
right now
uh 95 grand 95 000. what what did it
earn for you this year
two percent it's the uh allied bank oh
you're
killing it oh yeah this guy is
killing it ninety five thousand dollars
imagine
400 years away imagine if he had 95 000
employees okay that money earned can you
do the math up for me what is that
yeah two percent it's like 19 no no no
it's like
eighteen hundred bucks nineteen hundred
dollars
you're killing it man you're killing it
dogs okay
hey grant grant i got an idea for you
can i share it with you
no no no i wanna talk about how you even
make sense of this
i don't want to hear your ideas right
now all i know is your ideas are bad
okay how can you even make sense of this
dude inflation's three percent
the rent on my property went up three
percent this year they're not even
paying you what you freaking
what rental price values went up
yeah i'm storing that up for the next
deal do you own a home let me ask you
this do you own a home in vegas
you know yeah good good good for you
okay
okay you got any 401k money no
i well i got a hundred grand in that but
i took it out to um
i've got three rental properties there
you go that's in the business and i've
done all this since
august okay you just inspired me to so
dude get rid of this 95 all right
yep well if i get another five grand i
can call ryan secco
i'll get here i'll get you to five grand
right now
you will yeah we'll figure it out i'll
have it next thursday when i get paid so
let's get you still we'll get you going
today i don't want to wait and you can
give me the five grand next week
okay okay we'll do that but
yeah okay you have a great idea though
let me hear your great idea
now grant you got to hear it man so i
signed up for cardone you
must i've been in medical sales for the
last 12 years i love the program
but what i was thinking that a way to
help you you always have businesses that
need people
uh you know good employees and employers
or people out there in the workforce
that want to find good businesses to
work with
yeah my idea for is set up a
like a job board or a forum for the two
of those you've got two independent
people
bring them together you know cardone
trained
you know people that can work in cardone
businesses does that make sense
does anybody here know what he's talking
about nobody here knows what you're
talking about no all right
so i mean i'm i'm thinking there's a
good idea somewhere in there but it's
like a horse you know it's like we're
looking for the horse
only because we see the sh there got to
be a heart somewhere
here where's that pony
where's that pony there's a pony for it
let me have secco call you let's start
with the let's start with what we know
is gonna work
hook him up okay i like that dude though
man okay
look the guy's got it the guy at least
confronts the situation
he's like i got 95 in the bank pulled my
money out of my retirement account he's
buying rental properties
here's my prediction stock market is
going to roll
over etfs and mutual fund will lead the
way
possibly in the beginning of new year
there's just too much money in it okay
home equity if you have equity in your
home
and you want to capitalize and maximize
on the amount your home is worth today
now is the time to sell it sell your
house into spring
of next year try to get out of your
house as fast as you can
these values and homes will go down
okay if you if the stock market gets hit
six seven
eight thousand points and it could it
could easily get hit that hard
home values in america will go down
properties of cash flow
will not go down they will provide cash
flow
don't you hate my message he loves it we
got we got visitors today okay so
all your wives i know your wives hate my
guts they're like we ain't leaving the
house
i love my house i know where the kitchen
is you guys out there that can't get
your wife off the house thing man
show your wife show your wife what a
five million dollar house would rent for
okay go go if you're living in a million
dollar house
show her what living in a five million
dollar rental house that you guys could
move in and out of every 15 months if
you wanted to
i got a buddy just moved to my building
30 33 000
a month he pays to live in my building
okay he sold his home and he's selling
his home in in orange county he's
getting out he's getting his equity
he's going to come over here and pay 400
500 grand a year to live
to drive but he can leave in a year then
go live in costa rica if he wants
he can live wherever he wants but who
knows what's going to happen he can go
live in panama he can go back to
california live there for a year
he can go to arizona go to you guys need
to be able to move around man
the adventure there's no adventure in a
house
what's the adventure
oh the kid's security the kids the kids
the kids
the kids are gonna leave as soon as they
can
at nine they're ready to i went out of
here
okay let's talk to our last caller
the reason you don't have more money
john is because you guys don't make
money a priority you guys make
work a priority weekends are priority
having fun's a priority okay saving
money is a priority i don't want to save
money dude i want money to multiply i
wanted to have babies
hey grant i want my money to take over
the world
i'm working on that now i'm actually
looking into cardone capital
my thing is you know i have about i did
the math last night i have 143
liquid between my house the 401k yeah
i know i made a lot of decisions before
uh
my question i don't know if this is the
right time but with cardone capital
yeah you know this i know you're having
a discussion on saturday
if i put in let's say 20 25 grand
into that what would the cash flow do
you think
be on that monthly first of all if you
put
yeah if you put in a hundred thousand
let's just deal with a hundred thousand
because you got 143 000. you shouldn't
do 25 grand dude you should do all your
money
like i keep telling you guys like i know
you think i'm a fanatic
the reason i'm rich is because i do it
all i put it all in the formula
i don't put any money in apple stock
nothing in facebook i'm not buying
anything i don't have any etfs no mutual
funds
too many people went there study history
where every where
where everyone goes things go bad
this this will earn five thousand
dollars a year okay every hundred grand
earns about five
to six thousand dollars a year so i got
an email this morning
uh here's the deal that we bought we
thought it was gonna distribute six
percent a year
we have great news the reserve at points
port st lucie operations performed ahead
of expectations
during 2018. i'm reading it to you i
just got this at uh
at uh 10 36 this morning accordingly
you will receive a distribution in the
amount of 14 000
or 7 this earns five
that's what we paid at this property and
at the end of the year
we had a bigger distribution the
property performed better
and we distributed another seven percent
so when i tell you guys
i'm aiming for five it doesn't mean i
can't get to 12.
if i can i will why would i want to do
that
i own the damn thing like it's not like
i
i don't want to pay the investors i am
the investor i am the number one
investor
so i'm borrowing money from the bank at
four and a half percent
now the banks the richest institutions
in the world
think that this is a lot of money
otherwise they wouldn't lend me the
money everybody agree with that
and they put it into this
hundreds of millions of dollars billions
of dollars
are lended against these properties
to one person they're not going to do
that with a house you go to
you go to them with the house and say i
have a one billion dollar house to buy
okay the bank's not going to lend you
no matter how much money you put down
they're like no no no we're not going to
give you a loan for one house but we
will give you
700 million dollars worth of loans or a
billion dollars worth of loans
against these properties you buy why
okay
cash flow man cash flow those homes that
you're being sold right now
is to fund banks banks want to give
everybody little loans okay because they
make money like that
they don't care if it goes back most of
them won't go back only ten percent will
or eight percent
none of this is going to go back these
properties don't go back these
properties that i'm on
they don't trade hands people keep them
for eight and ten years
so this is what i would do dude i would
have have this protect
get your five percent plus
you got a shot at the appreciation okay
just so you know my goal
on that that project is to return you
two
to three times your money my goal is not
to return you five percent i'm not
trying to make five percent of my money
i'm trying to make five percent of my
money get my money to go work for me
earn five percent passive cross my
fingers
hope that i picked the right property
and i wait for the right moment somebody
comes along and says i want to buy that
property maybe we improve the rents
maybe it could happen that i improve the
rents and the five percent goes up just
like in my property here
maybe the rents go up if the rents go up
what happens more cash flow for us
and the more the cash flow goes up the
more the property appreciates
if we bought the right thing my goal is
my goal for every hundred grand i put in
i want to send out
two to three hundred thousand dollars
does it take five years six years seven
years i don't really care i'm looking
for a double and a triple
while i wait for my double in a triple i
want a little drip
okay a bunt a bun a bunt a bunt i get on
first base i get them first base i get
i keep getting no first base dude i'm
gonna freaking make it all the way
around most people never get to first
base
that's why they never score and so the
the the asset class
the asset class has to be this it has to
be real assets
it cannot be stocks it cannot be bonds
bonds cannot go
up okay like they're just not
it's risky it's a piece of paper i mean
i guess it could go up
but it's too risky you have to time it
right apple stock could go up could go
down
i don't know what's going to happen what
if somebody comes out with a new phone
is there a chance in your lifetime that
some technology could possibly replace
this right
it's not like i love apple i just got it
i just have it
but you showed me a better way you
showed me a way to make phone calls
without a phone
if i had to tell you 50 years ago i'd be
making phone calls for this you'd be
like no
wait how about this how about we make
phone calls one day and we don't have a
device
okay so i don't want to be invested in
that because that can go away
where i live is not going away amazon
will not disrupt it
apple computer will not disrupt it
microsoft will not disrupt it i have to
live
some place i don't see how they go
artificial on that
i need heat i need a place to live i'd
love to have a big freaking fancy ass
swimming pool
you got a million dollar house dude my
my properties have two and three million
dollar swimming pools
so i'm gonna tell you the last thing i'm
gonna tell you guys is this the wave the
wave
in the next over the next 10 to 15 or 20
years is going to be to the entire
all of america is going to be living at
these complexes that i'm talking about
these complexes i'm buying today i
believe
with a hundred percent of who i am
all of america not part of america
everybody is gonna start moving to these
facilities where there's two and three
hundred families
at beautiful complexes very secure
cameras uh theaters swimming pools
great gyms you won't have to go you
don't have to go to 24 hour fitness some
of my gyms
are better than the 24 hours at fitness
and and people are going to move to that
and that's being backed by investments
like blackstone and goldman sachs and
the wells fargos and the bank of america
they're investing their money in these
kind of products the reason you don't
have mo money is because you're not
committed
to getting your money to grow up and
multiply itself
any civilization that refuses to
multiply will cease to exist
the french will lose paris
the english will lose london
why because they don't multiply their
tribe
okay the italians will lose all of italy
the japanese will lose japan
those that refuse to multiply
will cease to exist and that certainly
applies
to your money now i've got some special
bonus clips that i think you're gonna
enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line of
the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
you will never lose in life if you have
valuable skills
you won't lose your house you won't lose
your car you won't lose your clients if
you have a skill that brings people
value
the economy can collapse the algorithms
can change
but as long as you have a skill that
solves problems for people
you will be safe so i'm seeing this a
lot in the youtube world now
i have a new course out helping people
get to a million subscribers on youtube
we can link up the description there if
you want in
and people are saying well should i
still do youtube is it too late like
youtube won't be here in five years or
ten years or maybe it's gonna be the
next thing that should hop on
it's not about the platform like right
now it's winning the platform that is
currently winning
you need to crush it right like youtube
should be your home if you're trying to
make an impact you're trying to be a
thought leader you have a message to
spread youtube has to be your number one
place it just has to be
right now otherwise you're not making a
smart decision but whether youtube is
still around in 20 years
five years doesn't matter because the
skill set that you learn
you can take anywhere the ability to
communicate you could take to any
platform you could take to the next
thing
i don't anticipate youtube still being
around in 20 years but my ability to
make videos
talking to a lens that's not gonna go
away
that can serve me for life right whether
that's vr evan
or hologram evan you know coming into
your living room that's that's gonna be
me that's gonna be amazing i'm pumped i
look forward to it
any algorithm change that people are
freaking out about anybody who's
complaining about
the economy going down or the algorithm
changing you've already lost that's a
losing mindset
when i was first starting my youtube
channel i always saw the algorithm as a
chance to win
right you should see if you're a small
creator on any platform
youtube instagram anything and the
algorithm shifts
that's your greatest advantage you
should be cheering you should want more
algorithm changes
if you look at a traditional established
boring market
uh it's hard to win real estate could be
hard to win
right financial markets can be hard to
win it's not that it's not possible it's
just hard to win because there's a lot
of people who have
who have decades of experience and no
more than you and it's hard to close
that gap of experience
with social media with youtube every
time there's a big algorithm change the
people who are experts at the last thing
they're crying instead of adjusting
that's how you win
that's how you get ahead of them that's
how you become the top dog
is because you're gonna go learn the new
algorithm when everybody is
wishing and hoping that the old
algorithm comes back and this happens
for every platform it happened for
facebook every time they changed your
algorithm or updated the
the feed and what was shown there people
always freak out and complain and they
sign they want petitions and like let's
go back to what it used to be
don't sign those petitions don't jump on
that bang when that is loser thinking
never
ever ever ever ever ever ever do that
it's loser thinking and that's how most
people think that's a mindset shift that
i want to make
for the collective but more importantly
for you
that whenever there's a big change
embrace it go all in on it learn it
that's how you're going to leapfrog
everybody else
so the faster the rate of change the
more you should be cheering i still get
pumped for an algorithm change
me i mean now i'm at now i'm closer to
the top right i mean i don't know what
the top is i got 2 million subscribers
and
300 million views and all these channels
i still love it anytime
an algorithm change comes out i'm still
pumped train yourself like a change is
coming i'm pumped
get excited because there's still people
who are ahead of me or even the people
below me that i'm competing with
for for attention and for space if
they're sitting there complaining about
how it's changed and they're dropping in
their views awesome i'll pick up those
views because i'm going to learn what
the new algorithm is all about
same thing with the economy when the
economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be
they're not going to win
it's comforting to join a club and wish
things to be how they used to be but
we're not going back to that so the
faster you realize
that and make improvements the faster
you can learn and actually build a great
business
some of the greatest businesses in the
world are built in recession
in depression that could be you if you
decide to be
let's hop back to skills for a second i
look at jake paul logan paul they
started on
vine right vine was was their claim to
fame they had tons of success in making
these
super short videos vine gets shut down
right
boom gone this is don't put all your
eggs in one basket
i think that's loser thinking too it's
loser thinking
they went all in on vine and and then
vine got shut down oh no
what did they do they moved to youtube
and started crushing it millions of
subscribers look at their growth on
youtube
over the past i don't know two years
three years blew up
why they didn't just come out of nowhere
they had the skill set
they had the skill set that they learned
from doing the thing
right the skill set to make a good video
they then brought to a new platform if
youtube goes away
you're learning the skill set of how to
communicate how to make great videos
that whatever comes next people are
freaking out about
the ftc coming in and cop on youtube
okay so if kids aren't
able to get content on youtube where
they're gonna go go be there
instead of trying to fight what is
already happening
go be at the place where the kids are
going to be
embrace the change that's where you
that's where you can win when everybody
else is fighting and angry and screaming
and yelling and complaining and wishing
that it used to be or quitting the
platform and
getting upset go be where they're going
to be it's it's easy it's a simple win
most people don't have that mindset it's
why most people lose my most businesses
can't evolve most most businesses are
shut down it's people
very rarely transition from one platform
to another from
one business to another even though they
have the skill sets and capabilities to
do so because they don't have the
mindset to do so
people who crushed myspace very few of
them are still around
on different platforms looking look at
hollywood the rock is doing it
will smith is doing it moving from
hollywood films to youtube
where's brad pitt where's george clooney
like they're in a dying industry
they should be embracing youtube they
don't want to they have the skills they
have the skills it's transferable
you don't think george clinton could
come in and crush youtube if you wanted
to
of course he could calling you out
george clooney let's go
make it happen right so it's about
picking up the skill set that will keep
you safe in any environment
but it's also having a mindset to follow
through and try the new things instead
of complaining about the changes that
are currently happening
so how can you do it i'm gonna give you
a three-step process that i think will
help
step one is make sure your actions map
to your missions this will help you
determine what skill set you need what
are your ambitions what do you want to
accomplish what do you want in our life
there's so many ways to win you know if
you've gone through the who why how
process you know what your purpose is
you know what you're trying to
accomplish you've
you've read built a survey you can't
read it yet still in pre-order but
you understand the concept you figure
out your purpose great to actually go
off and accomplish it
what are the skill sets that you
actually need what are the skills that
you need to develop even if you suck at
it if you're not naturally good at it
i'm introverted i'm not naturally good
in front of the camera it took me
six thousand videos to get here right i
got better with practice and repetition
and dedication
hard work and all of that you can too
what are the skill sets that you need
to acquire to get the life that you want
and then you can start working on them
so first step is figure out how do you
map your actions to your ambitions
second step is to learn to tell yourself
that it's the best it's the best
it's the best every time something
negative is happening to you
the economy is crashing and algorithm is
changing a new competitor comes in
something something negative is
happening
you tell yourself it's the best this is
the best is my chance
to prove to myself and the world what
i'm made of
when an algorithm changes and you say
it's the best
you're going to find a new solution if
you sit there and complain and get
negative and toxic you're not going to
find a new solution the best part of
saying it's the best
is it shifts your mindset from one of
complaining and lack of resourcefulness
to one of ultimate resources to be able
to say i'm gonna go solve this thing
let's go it shifts your mindset so many
people get stuck
in the negativity even if you're an
entrepreneur and you're positive and
optimistic and
have great hopes for the future where
you want to go if you spend all this
time and energy building up this thing
and it gets taken away from you it's
really hard to say this is the best
but that's what you need to do because
otherwise you spend the rest of your
life living off of past glory and say
well this is what i used to be and it
was all taken away from me and my life
sucks like you want the next 40 years of
your life to be
thinking like that no it's the best
the economy crashes it's the best you're
gonna crush it
algorithm changes it's the best you're
gonna crush it new competitor comes in
it's the best
you're gonna crush it right
you grow through difficult times you get
better to a difficult time
you don't want to do the same thing over
and over and over and over again that's
boring that's photocopying your life
that's not what you want
you want to grow you want to progress
self-confidence self-love
all of it comes from doing difficult
things by telling yourself that when
that difficult thing comes
it's the best this is my chance to rise
up
and show myself and the world what i'm
capable of
as opposed to saying this sucks and sit
in negativity
all day all week all month all year
all decade and step number three is
understand that the quantity leads to
the quality we figured out what our
skill is that we want to get good at
right
we understand that it's the best that
when other people are complaining we're
gonna rise up and improve our skills and
get better at the thing because that's
how we're gonna win
and now number three is the practice the
daily grind the
constant improvement i've done six
thousand videos that's how i got better
at this
the thing that you want to get great at
you have to do a lot of you're gonna
suck at the beginning
you're not gonna have any quality that's
okay that's great it's the best right
but then through repetition through
practice through daily hustle
attacking the thing the thing that you
love doing even though other people see
it as work and torture
you love it you're getting better at it
that's how you're gonna improve your
skills
every skill set is possible to acquire
it's just a skill doesn't mean you suck
as a human just means you don't have the
skill set yet
how do you get the skill set by
practicing the quantity leads to the
quality and so back to point number one
of your actions mapped to your ambitions
how much are you practicing you want to
acquire the skill set how much time are
you actually spending on that skill set
you want to be a great editor great how
much time are you spending editing want
to be a great piano player how much time
you spending piano
right you might have some natural
ability for it awesome
and if you don't i had no natural
ability to be good in front of the
camera
go back and watch my first videos you'll
see you'll see how much i sucked
no natural ability zero this took a long
time
practice dedication hard work
right action snap to your ambitions by
putting the quantity that leads to
the quality how much are you doing show
me your calendar show yourself your
calendar pull up your calendar look at
your next week look at your next month
that skill that you want to acquire
that's going to save you
from the recession from the algorithm
change that's going to bring people
value that skill that you need to
acquire it's going to pay you
how much time you spend in developing it
and if it's not a lot if it's not
sometime every day you got to change
your mindset you got to change your
calendar you need to change your actions
because right now
if that's you your actions are not
mapping to your missions i want you to
win
you need to get the skill sets that's
the path the fastest path for you to get
to success you're after is to model
success
the idea here is simple you find people
who have already done the thing that you
want to do
learn from them understand what they did
to get there and then try
on their hat right see what worked for
them and apply it to your business
this is what worked for me this is what
saved my company bill gates
saved my first company even though i've
never met him i haven't yet
we're to make it happen hopefully
hopefully hopefully soon
i was struggling i had a upstart
software company that wasn't making
money
and i quit on my business partner and i
woke up the next day and said i need to
find a way to make this happen
like i can't quit on this too soon
because i'm going to regret it if i
don't keep going
and so i said who has done this before
who's done this
and i thought of bill gates which is the
first person that came to mind was bill
gates so i looked at his story and how
did he
build microsoft was through partnerships
and so i started making partnerships in
my business
i had nothing else to lose i was already
at rock bottom right here quit on my
partner
it was hopeless so let's just give this
a shot
and within i don't know a couple months
maybe even sooner
i landed my first partnership deal for
13 and a half thousand dollars and at
the time guys i was making 300 bucks a
month so that money
meant the world to me like that was that
was bank and and more important than
that it
it gave me hope you know like this could
happen this
this business could actually work and it
gave me a model to then go and do it
again and again and again
and ever since then whenever i don't
know what to do i model success i find
someone who's done it
and i try to apply their strategies and
make it work for me
but this is the important thing not
every strategy is going to work the same
way
for them as it did for you so maybe
waking up early is your ticket maybe
waking up later
is going to be your ticket there's
people who've done both which is the one
that's going to work for you
you won't know by sitting on the couch
and thinking about it the best thing you
can do
is just go and try you try on their hat
right bill gates did this dan lok does
this bruce lee does this
awesome try it try it and see people
pre-judge
so early you have to change your habits
if you want to get something more than
you have right now it's because you're
doing something different than what
you're doing right now
and different is scary different means
you don't know what's going to work out
or not different
is different we don't want to do
different right you want to stay inside
our comfort zone that's not where your
success is going to come
but not everything you try is going to
work even the ones that do work won't
work 100
the way that bill gates did partnerships
and his business is different than the
way that i did it
but just that idea alone took me 80
percent of the way modeling success
takes you eighty percent of the way and
then that final twenty percent is you
gotta
make the adjustments to make it your own
because otherwise you just end up being
a junior version of somebody else
instead of being you
but i think we're too often just judging
people you're judging a strategy saying
well that's not going to work for me
without even trying it
and so i have this channel where you can
learn from people every day i have my
top 10 rules where you can watch those
videos and learn from people every day
if you watch a top 10 video these are 10
rules for some of the most successful
people on the planet in the history of
humanity
here they are with 10 different lessons
not all of those 10 lessons have to work
for you have to apply to you
take one of them take two of them and
just do something just apply it to your
life apply it to your business and see
if you get a result
that's the key and so you need to get
out of your head you need to get out of
your own way and you need to just start
doing
the best thing you can do is go from
idea to action that when you
see something that kind of makes sense
that might be a fit for you
just start doing it stop judging
start doing it and apply it to your
business and see if it works
give it a shot if you want to sign up
for the entire billionaire mindset
series for free and get the companion
bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there